there's a super interesting article in
the Atlantic that I read and you know if
you've been listening to this show for a
while that I've been saying automation
and technology will destroy jobs in the
nineteen early nineteen hundreds at the
beginning of the 20th century new
technology destroyed some jobs but it
created new industries that led to even
more jobs so technology was a net
positive in terms of employment we are
now at the point where automation and
robots and technology getting so
advanced that there is no longer a net
positive effect technology in the next
20 years is going to destroy jobs and
not create enough new industries or jobs
to make up for that transportation we've
talked about many times we've got
driverless ubers already in Pittsburgh
up although temporarily you still need
to have a draw huge hole of the vehicle
we have uh we did a story recently about
driverless drone farm tractors which are
going to drastically up and agriculture
we already know about the driverless
truck corridor that is in place I forget
exactly where somewhere in the mountains
of the United States and in mountain
time zone we know about automated or
mining trucks that are already operating
in Canada this is happening so first of
all you agree Rachel that there is
really no turning back the flow of
technology at this point and saving jobs
merely for the sake of not uh
eliminating certain industries right but
I also think that if you're in the
technology sector there's going to be
more jobs because they need people who
are engineering all these technologies
and who are writing the code and who are
creating the robots oh yeah but then if
you're in a position of say someone who
is in customer service then it's going
to be um it's going to take over so
there's no doubt that automation is
going to create some jobs it's just that
the net effect is going to be negative
very very negative so anyway I read this
very interesting article in the Atlantic
called the next Industrial Revolution
and of course it predicts that we are
going to see they're calling it the next
Industrial Revolution but really what
we're talking about is automation and
self-driving cars health care robots
there's no doubt in my mind that for
many medical procedures robots are
eventually going to be better and have a
lower lower error rate then live human
surgeons for for many many procedures
this is going to as the article in the
Atlantic suggests destroy millions and
millions of jobs and uh yeah I don't
know how anyone can really disagree with
that at this point I know that it's kind
of sad in a way but for years every time
I talked about self-driving cars people
would email me and they'd say David
you're wasting time I mean this this is
just it's just not happening and today
we have self-driving cars being piloted
in countless countries and if you
believe that the pilots are gonna fail
and everybody will say you know what we
tested it and we're not doing it you're
sort of living in a fantasy world I
think the biggest risk that we can make
as a as a society of humans right now
rachel is to focus only on denial that
this is happening and ignore thinking
about what changes we need to make to
adapt to this coming change I think that
is the biggest risk we should be talking
about basic income we should be talking
about so many things and if we ignore
that that's really concerning to me I
think so too but I also believe that
people aren't acknowledging the fellow
maybe they're acknowledging but they're
having trouble accepting that if there's
certain things that the human brain is
not equipped to understand or it's just
too much information looking at big data
for instance if we can train a computer
or a machine deep neural network to
understand that information then we're
going to advanced society and while that
that then may push some jobs under the
rug so to speak those advances could are
instrumental if if we adjust our
expectations of society in the right way
right I mean we just need to stay if we
eliminated the need for everybody to
have a full-time job in order to subsist
one of two things could happen the
people who have the jobs that won't be
automated will do fine and everybody
else is going to basically sink into
poverty and will become a dystopian
horrible society the likes of which you
see in science fiction books and movies
that's one way could go
the other way could go as we say hey you
know what we've gotten so advanced as a
culture that now basically people can
get by with 20 hour a week jobs because
we've established a basic income because
we are moving post-scarcity when it
comes to things like basic food supply
basic shelter etcetera these these uh
amenities need no longer be rationed in
a way where the poor don't get them and
we're gonna rethink everything we're
doing and you're not your your
well-being is not going to be as
directly connected to employment I I get
you look very skeptical over there
Rachel and I get that this is sort of
like a long road that we're going to go
down but if we don't think about this in
a real way we're just going to see a
broadening of the wealth uh wealth
inequality and income gap and it's going
to be sort of bad for everybody we'll
continue talking about it check out this
article uh the next Industrial
Revolution